I am opening our executive session on
sv14 and I'm also recessing it one of
our members had a uh had an urgent uh
issue she'll be right back
foreign
I'm reopening executive session on House
Bill excuse me on Senate bill 14.
and I am making a motion to reconsider
second
I will speak to my motion
the purpose of this reconsideration is
only solely to amend the bill by adding
house bills 473
House Bill 473 passed this committee
unanimously it would change first time
possession of a controlled substance to
a misdemeanor instead of a felony
they passed the house floor I believe on
a Voice vote it's the position of the
house
the reason I'm advocating for this bill
is because we have entirely too many
people at a very young age being turned
into felons because of their a mistake
at 19 or 20 years old you have a college
kid who may have picked up some
mushrooms at a party
and in the middle of his college career
is now a felon
he cannot join the military he cannot
vote for a period of time he can never
possess a firearm he could never become
a fish and game officer
he could never become a number of things
he'd never qualified for um Federal
housing I could spend an hour on the
list of things that we just disqualified
that person from because our first
offense is a felony
I believe that in the house believes
that uh Second Chance for someone making
a mistake like this is an order it gives
them a chance to get court ordered help
and keeps them from being a felon and
having the rest of their life ruined
that is the reason that I am advocating
adding this bill
it is my hope that this adding this bill
the Senate will request a committee of
conference where we can at least discuss
the bill
having said that I believe the
importance of sb14 and if it is at the
end of the day the position that we
cannot come to a good agreement with the
Senate I will a seed to drop in this at
that time but I do intend to at least
have the conversation we convinced 400
people who represent 1.6 million people
that this is the policy the state wants
and I believe it's worth a conversation
with the 25 people in the other body
would you like to speak to a second
no thank you Mr chairman you covered it
I think that the uh the merits of HB 473
are are unquestioned by uh most of the
members on this committee uh and and by
myself
um
the first time we saw this bill
um this committee passed at 18-2 and
sent it on to the Full House with an
enthusiastic recommendation
the issue isn't our like or or dislike
for HB 473 here the issue is whether or
not attaching this bill to sb14 uh will
hurt the chances of Passage uh for for
SB 14 which is a very good bill which
many of us have received a lot of emails
on over the last few weeks
um
I looked at the docket
for uh for HB 473 and one of the things
that I saw was that this was not a 13 to
11 vote in the Senate it was an 11-6
um
we're not in a situation where we need
to convince one or two senators
we're in a situation where in order for
what would be both bills to pass
we would need to flip seven votes in the
Senate
um that just seems like an
extraordinarily uh difficult thing to do
at this stage
we also have the option of bringing 473
back in the next session and I would be
the first to say I would be proud to be
a co-sponsor of this bill in the next
session but I I will not support the
reconsideration motion
because frankly
we've already seen one good bill go down
in the Senate
473. the idea that we could actually see
two good bills go down in the Senate as
part of this process would be a little
bit too much to take
um so uh I'll be voting against the
motion for reconsideration and I hope my
colleagues will do the same thank you
I would um respond to to my colleague by
saying I do not believe that the will of
the 400 should be somehow thwarted or
scared by what may happen in the other
body
I believe that we should press our our
position I believe that a committee of
conference they are quite capable of
saying no again and if we can't get the
votes then we see then but to give up at
this point on what I think is a very
important piece of legislation
I dare say more important than SB 14
making felons out of our young people to
me seems
um
seems very important frankly I I've
I feel odd being the one in argue in
this position but so be it I am
um with regard to the emails I recall
getting literally probably a thousand
emails about bail and I stood firm for
this committee
and it took a lot of heat for it
um not passing bills from the Senate
so I would I would expect that a similar
courtesy would be paid
having said that we will see what
happens anyone else wish to discuss Mr
uh I will not be supporting this of the
reconsideration also
and the reason is is I think that uh
this the the bill that we are the bill
that we're going to attach to it
it reduced the penalty sum but with the
conditions of what happened the way it
had it lost in the Senate
adding that bill to this good bill that
gives the people that have give them
rights over their own personal property
um
for not to have surveillance cameras put
there by anybody at any time
is a good bill and I I'm just not going
to kill a good bill by attaching a
defeated Bill to it and see both of them
go down in flames so I will not be
thank you any further discussion
seeing none I think we've we've made our
positions clear and
oh
yes you may
um we're going to take a two-minute
recess
okay we are resuming the executive
session
um further discussion before we call the
roll
seeing none I will ask the clerk to call
the roll the motion on the floor is to
amend
um
or excuse me reconsideration thank you
for correcting me
um go ahead Vice chair Rhodes
yes representative Pratt no
representative scitec
representative Melvin yes representative
janvan
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tensar yes
representative gathright
representative news no representative
sorry
um representative goalie
no
representative Murphy no representative
Newman
no
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell no
representative Brennan no
representative wheeler no
chairman Roy
uh 11 years nine days
motion carries
bill is amended by about 11-9
okay so at this point I make a motion
to amend
second
um I don't think we need any further
discussion I think we've we all unless
anybody wishes to make a further comment
represent scitec this is all repetitive
but I want to say it perhaps anyway
quickly
the chairman is Will undoubtedly be on a
committee of conference and is prepared
to jettison got to get close to the
microphone it is prepared to jettison
this but so that there's no real risk
it's under virtually impossible
anything's possible that the Senate
would just get rid of the bill entirely
I wouldn't I would not go with that
I'm going with the idea that uh if they
don't exceed to say a misdemeanor a that
he is willing as uh to to get rid of
this part of it and keep sb14 and I
that's I know we've we differ but that's
I don't know why I'm talking to you but
anyway all right
thank you
representative Muse
I did want to say that there there has
been a little bit uh more than the usual
degree of animosity over the last few
weeks uh between between the house and
the Senate so I I think that
passing an amendment like this uh is a
calculated risk and it does uh put SB 14
at risk
and uh and I think that's a shame
thank you
representative wheeler
I just wanted to really quickly thank
you for letting me speak I just wanted
to quickly explain my vote of someone
who is I think voted for more drug
legalization bills than anyone in this
committee I didn't support this one
today not because I don't support the
bill but because I like representative
Muse just said I'm worried about the
risk that this takes to the game cameras
bill I had I think over 15 constituents
reach out in Peterborough that was more
than any uh had reached out for any
other Bill around this bill because they
had had people putting cameras on their
properties they've had problems with
them being filmed and so I at the risk
of losing that even if it is a small one
I think it might be a little bit bigger
than small I I cannot uh in good
conscience vote for for the amendment
which would put this on to the the game
cameras bill when the game cameras bill
is so important to the people in
Peterborough
and and I would um encourage any member
obviously to listen to their
constituents I would however say that
the risk of the Senate killing this with
me saying in advance if we cannot come
to an agreement I am happy to jettison
this bill from 14 the only reason the
Senate would kill it and not accede to a
five-minute Committee of conference
would be Spite and I cannot believe in
good conscience that our our colleagues
on the other side would even contemplate
such thing
um so that's my response to that I do
not in any Universe see them killing it
especially in advance I
um I've heard from Members say that they
would take it if we made it misdemeanor
a we can do that in a community
conference in five minutes and be done
um I I think that we will all come
together as a team I can't imagine them
doing such a thing representative scitec
of course there's what risk is there
agreed it is indeed their bill and they
do want it and
having said that see no further oh Mr
representative Muse again
one last thing I want to make very very
clear is what we have here is in a
disagreement in policy uh for the most
part I think we're on board with sp14 as
well as uh HP
497. what we have here is a disagreement
and strategy
um and uh and and hopefully we will come
to the correct strategy that will
actually ensure that sb14 passes thank
you
agreed uh I think at the end of the day
the main goal is for SB 14 to pass and I
will not in any way jeopardize that at a
committee of conference but I do at the
same time
recognize the will of the 400 that sent
this bill to the Senate
on behalf of the 1.6 million who said we
are tired of making our young people in
in particularly according to the latest
reports I've seen people of color
become felons more than anyone else and
have their lives ruined before they've
even started
um with that I will ask the clerk to
call the roll
chairman
I think I agree with the representative
Muse that there's a
the this I don't think it's spite that
anybody on this side voted against
reconsideration I think that was
probably a poor choice of words I wasn't
talking about us talking about the
Senate I said if the Senate were to kill
it knowing that I already agreed to
throw this out if they don't like it
then I I sincerely apologize for my
obvious need for a hearing aid
no worries
at the end of this any anyway I agree
with him that this is we don't know for
sure and I don't I believe this is how
the system works we don't know for sure
that there will be a committee of
conference on this bill we don't know
that
so so right now what we have is we have
a bill that we know is a good bill that
passed here and is on consent I believe
and that we should not be using this
bill
to attach the other Bill too because I
think there is a good probability only
if you do the math it lost 18 to six
and I doubt that you're going to swa
you're gonna get six people devote it so
it may go to a committee of conference
in a committee of conference and again I
am not completely sure how it works I
think if you could take this bill off
and the amended bill that we're sticking
on here if we if we can take it off
I believe in a committee of conference
You could argue for the fact that you
ought to put it on that bill and then
you'd have something to work with so
anyway even with that case
um that that's actually impossible
because there would be no Committee of
conference because we would have just
agree to the bill the only time there's
a committee is if there's a disagreement
in in between the two bills
um anyway having said that I think I've
made my point clear
um and I said oh representative wheeler
so I've been mulling this for the last
two minutes after I just spoke
um
I voted against reconsideration I stand
by that vote because I don't think we
should have reconsidered it
however now that we're here at the
amendment
piece I feel
maybe I should vote for the amendment
and I think I think I might I just
wanted to say that so it wasn't a
surprise
made Linda laugh that's a good day
that's all I care about um so I'm going
to vote for the amendment because like I
agree I agree with you Mr chairman that
we do need to address this I think the
other legalization bills have gotten to
a a point where they won't go any
further and we could seriously address
this problem by actually passing this
this bill and you know if it's going to
be
what if we do what representative Newman
just suggested it's essentially amending
the bill on a committee of conference so
why not just do that right now
um so I'm going to vote for the
amendment and to be clear we can't do
that in the committee of conference at
it because there would be no committee
conference there's only a Community
Conference if we differ between the
bills that gets sent back and forth so
if this is not amended it just goes
forth and the Senate takes and it's done
representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman I I was going to say this
before representative Willer spoke and
then I I've been going back and forth so
what I would really like to say is this
there are a lot of bills that that we
have compromised and and came up with
verbiage in this committee that for for
one reason another a lot of us really
didn't like but we listened to what
people were saying and we took a chance
to get it out of this committee
and
this is a perfect example of that 18
people in this committee voted for this
bill because you prefer for 473 my
recommendation is take a chance take a
chance
and if those are the committee of
conference the chairman will do what he
said he's never ever went back on his
word anybody in this committee
take a chance
trust the process
let's give it a try
thank you Mr chairman let's vote
representative Newman one more time I've
okay I just I just had one
misunderstanding one thing I'm not clear
about
when we talked about this bill we
meaning our conference
and that was that my understanding is
that two bills were held we held the
camera game camera bill and the tree
stand bill
I don't know why we this isn't attached
to the tree stand bill I think if it was
attached to the tree stand bill which
does not have the significance of this
game camera bill it um I would vote for
that I would but I think that this the
game camera build is so important and I
think the outcome would be the same when
it made to the Senate
it would kill that bill but it wouldn't
be as bad thank you oh wait though um
maybe representative Newman is on to
something I need to check
um
unfortunately it was only um it was only
noted as 14 in the calendar
representative Newman have had both been
listed for public I could have done that
but only 14 was in the calendar so I
seeing nothing representative well it's
my big chance representative Muse has
talked about our disagreeing and
strategy and I he's right and I hope
that I don't know whether what side will
prevail but if if it I hope that we're
the
that the Senate goes along with it I
hope that this our strategy is correct
because here's my point I as you know I
say this maybe too often I bail people
who they're they're caught with some
drugs and the police have to charge a
felony and I'm looking at somebody and
it's a sad sack it's not a criminal I
mean
yeah of Court breaking the law criminal
but it's just not some my heart's not in
it but I gotta do it and the sooner we
get this to say a Class A uh the the
better and
that's all
I also wanted to add one more Point um
the pushback we got from law enforcement
or that I heard in the Senate was
this is a tool we use we need this tool
because we get people to plead to the
misdemeanor if they don't have the
felony hanging over and frankly I find
that reprehensible that's what happens
in Washington we charge people in the
state with what they have committed not
with what something higher so they'll
plead guilty to what they committed
because it's too risky to fight for
their own innocence that I find that
whole concept and argument um contrary
to to our very system of justice that
was founded on the principle that 10
guilty men should walk free rather than
one innocent man go to jail so that
argument I won't even entertain
representative wheeler really quickly Mr
chairman I want you to get your lawn I
just wanted to mention for some of my
friends on the other side that the ACLU
has mentioned that they do support this
amendment so when I was first confronted
with the reconsideration vote I was
confronted with a I was going to have to
vote against the ACLU my first time so I
just I the organizations that support
the the the bill do say that this is a
risk that's worth taking and I think
that's uh important to mention
I think the point that I'm working with
the Asia you should frighten everyone
more than that having said that now
please call the vote
motion on the floor is to adopt
um I'll spill 473 and amend it onto
sp14.
good Vice chair Rhodes
yes representative Pratt no
representative scitec
representative Melvin yes representative
janfrin yes representative Banyan yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tensar yes
representative Catherine
representative muse no representative
Bolden yes representative goalie
representative Murphy no representative
Newman no the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes
representative Brennan no representative
wheeler
chairman Roy
CE yes 13 years that's seven days
motion carries the amendment is attached
these bills will go to the clerk today I
thank you all for your deliberation and
consideration final was 13 to what
you know
bro
hello actually hold on we this is this
is we're we're in some uh complicated um
Waters here I think we may need to at
this point vote
otpa now that we've amended it so I make
second by representative Stone
please no further discussion does anyone
talking no the clerk uh I would ask the
clerk to call the roll off the passes
men
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt no representative scitec
representative Melvin yes representative
Jan Fran
aye representative Manion
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tanzar yes
representative Catherine
representative news yes
representative Bolden yes representative
Brennan
or Golia sorry representative goalie no
representative Murphy no
representative Newman no the clerk votes
yes representative Newell yes
representative Brennan no
representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy
CE yes
motion is 14 years six news
Moshe carries 14-6
ought to pass as amended in as I said
previously this will be referred to the
clerk this afternoon to go on the next
available house session where this still
gets to be debated before the whole
house
so that's before we even get to a
question of a committee of conference so
I thank you all for your time and
deliberation and I trust we are all
I appreciate it
love to see how everyone next time
everybody
foreign